تحدث عن الخبر اذا الابرز العنوان الابرز
حيث اعلن منذ قليل نادي النصر السعودي ضم
المهاجم برتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو رسميا
الى صفوفه بعقد يمتد لعامين ونصف العام
الاعلام والتوقيع العقد كان في العاصمه
الاسبانيه مدريد وقع رونالدو اذا على عقد
يلعب بموجبه في صفوف النصر حتى عام 2025
وسيحمل لرونالدو القميص الرقم سبعه
اذا الصفقه التاريخيه تمت اييه كابتن طارق
يعني كيف يمكن لنا ان نصف ما حدث من صفقه
بين النصر السعودي والنجم الكبير
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
السعوديه في الكره السعوديه في الكره
العربيه عامتا والكره الاسيويه عارف انه
رونالدو يبحث دائما عن الارقام وخيار
للنصر السعودي
الوحيد لبقائه في اوروبا
همم
اللي ممكن
يكون همم اولا يجري وراء رقم همم لانه
عنده خمسه
سنين همم
وهذا مهم جدا الارقام هذه مهمه جدا
اهداف اخرى كثيره ممكن تعدل الالف هدف
لانه رونالدو مقرون بالارقام القياسيه لكن
من جهه اخرى نصره الكره السعوديه اصلا
الكره السعوديه هي احسن بطوله عربيه وتكون
متفق عليها الحين
في نفس النادي ممكن راموس هذا هذا هذا
اللاعبين النجوم راح تعمل
الكل تقريبا كل يكسب من خلال هذه الصفقه
همم كابتن طارق نتفق على ذلك اللاعب كما
ذكرت على الصعيد المهدي وهذا مهم جدا همم
في في عالم الاحتراف على الصعيد همم ربما
والتحدي الرياضي كما ذكره هو انه في اول
تعليق له كريستيانو رونالدو متحمس لهذه
التجربه همم الجديده وقال في ما قال ايضا
بانه مشروع عن النشره ايضا مهم جدا
الهام همم النصر السعودي ايضا على مستوى
الصوره تراند يعني ال- ال- الليله اعتقد
الكل حتى همم خارج عالمنا العربي همم الكل
ساذهب الى همم المواقع الخاصه بنشر سعودي
لكل سيتعرف عن نصر السعودي على كره القدم
السعوديه على المنطقه ايضا عموما يعني
مستوى الصوره مهم جدا همم ما حدث من صفق
طبعا مصر السعوديه
4 تقريبا 400 مليون صور انه هذه الناس
محبين رونالدو
ممكن مش محبي لكن راح يكونوا على الاقل
والنصر تاريخ
السعوديه مهمه جدا في
اسيا وراح ممكن يسبحون المحبين هذا النادي
وهذا مهم جدا